let's talk about Will Smith
congratulations to him because
apparently he made it through a midlife
crisis we'll drop that startling
revelation admitting that he struggled
when his daughter Willow hit a big-time
in the music biz she shaved her head
bald in the middle of her whip my hair
too right and I was like I definitely
had to forgive you and daddy
it was mostly daddy cuz he was so like
harsh will secretly cause 2012 the year
of the mutiny we're his family rejected
his leadership then eleven-year-old
willow in the middle of her whip my hair
tore reach the breaking point feeling
like I wasn't listened to or no one
cared what I felt yeah during that time
et was with the Smith family at the
height of willows fame why do what if
you're not gonna have fun but behind
closed doors Willow confessed she was
cutting herself in a new interview will
tells oat Living magazine he quit
Hollywood for two years so he could put
family first and yeah looks like
everyone's come out just fine cuz the
fellas come knockin on the door yeah you
know what we're looking into herself on
that one the first couple questions that
willow asked sort of shuts it down
[Music]